guardava facendo finta scritto benvenuti
dei livelli la grandissima richiesta al
nuovo gameplay ma questa volta faremo
uno scherzo ai fan perché useremo i
trucchetti e cioè i mod
abbiamo installato i trucchetti noi
useremo i trucchetti ma voi non sapete
che stiamo avrò di trucchi per cui
mister ha troppo divertente giocare con
voi senza che voi sappiate che stiamo
dando dentro che spero che non vi faremo
imposta trovo divertenti mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere un altro gameplay chi non lascia
mi piace verrà votato impostare lo
spariamo fuori dalla vicina in mente di
rigore ibridi bob caro perché sarà un
episodio troppo divertente le viziano
territorio uno dei trucchetti è che
abbiamo tutti i cappelli a disposizione
senza doverli pagare perché addio mista
che mette il cappello di natale abbiamo
anche tutti i pet che vogliamo quindi il
cane perché l'altra volta avete detto di
usare il cane anche qui ne abbiamo
quanti ne vogliamo di questo è uno dei
trucchetti grazie cari
bellissimo ammiro state già arrivando
ciao per questa partita abbiamo attivato
il trucchetto in cui sapremo dall'inizio
chi è l'importatore corradi l'accento
infatti potete vedere quindi noi sapremo
chi è l'impostore divertente che
scherzetti potevo fare a l'impostore
visto che sappiamo chi è potremo provare
a seguirlo spero stando attenti a non
essere uccisi ora spero di non essere io
stesso trucchetto più vedermi un
induttore pro capitare però possiamo
mettere altri trucchetti che ora mettere
aiuta le ecco con i nostri tocchetti di
non lo dica nessuno allora abbiamo
attivato il fatto che possiamo uccidere
quanto vogliamo senza avere il il tempo
quindi su hines avere senza avere la
pausa di tempo hai fatto il sabotaggio
delle luci così ci vedranno due o
qualcuno ha riportato il corpo scoperto
signora un po ti ho votato gli stati che
ha visto che stiamo usando i trucchetti
[Risate]
vediamo vediamo a mi ha votato solo
fianco per fortuna
arancione ricorda camminiamo quelli che
sospettano che dobbiamo trovarli ma
nessun endo sistemare le luci nel
frattempo ecco mi sento in colpa
e cosa troviamo qualcun'altro bianco e
arancione bianco arancione si per forza
di dobbiamo trovare hanno trovato un
corpo di già chi l'ha trovato il vert il
nord blu il blu blu blu scrivi anche tu
blu è stato blu usiamo il blu che sono a
vincere da impostori per la primissima
volta proprio no
[Risate]
non hai un pò storie che ci piace anche
ma no non peccato che quando sostituto
di turchetti purtroppo può succedere che
ti beccano e ti e finiscono la partenza
da bari dobbiamo iniziarne un'altra per
un fatto di cartelle che abbiamo fatto
una nuova partita già che ci sono cambio
cappello smetto il pacco regalo è messo
in crisi tivano sì possiamo iniziare
questa volta abbiamo scelto altri
trucchetti scoprirete subito vediamo
prima come abbiamo già nate sappiamo già
chi sono gli impostori
allora il turno abbiamo aggiunto sono
che sappiamo che l'impostore l'impostore
celeste marrone e rosa grazie ma scusa
chiede marrone di ammazzarlo
no no non ce la fai
ma che era tra l'altro morrone unite
dove il blu chiaro ha ucciso lite
davanti a noi
fidatevi in rosa siro sapendo non sono
stato io a rota si torni in col mondo
dicendo ma passando la parola su nero il
marrone mi è sembrato di vedere marrone
poi non lo so se mi sono battuto e blu
chiaro dicono anche più chiaro dottore
giusto sappiamo che abbiamo allora hanno
votato adesso è ok io chiamo l'emergency
meeting votiamo blues e noi vogliamo
errore centro community dicono rosa o
blu da think dei bravi ma per che cosa
stai incolpando un altro impostare è
forse non si è accorta che voglio
impostare come lei non ho fatto nulla
non è completamente diversa un buon rock
piccoli trucchi uno degli impostori
cioè praticamente il trucchetto che
abbiamo messo non ci è servito a niente
perché non possiamo fare dunque nella
scorsa partita si hanno beccato i
trucchetti sicuramente per il fatto che
abbiamo tolto il tempo quando uccidi ora
abbiamo disattivato quel trucchetto e
con questi non dovrebbero scoprirci il
russo le stesse entrato dentro il match
l'ha ucciso adesso incolperanno tutti i
blu una storia sono rosa e celeste
guarda celeste impostore di check in
favore di ieri spiegazione dai votato in
rosa dai hanno votato tutti in salita
era un'altra storia
ancora un impostore bravissime allora è
rimasto ancora un impostore è il marrone
abbiamo ti amo ti amo fare l'ossigeno
noi siamo più veloci da fantasmi così
almeno aiutiamo il resto della state
tutti lontani dal marrone sarebbe bello
avere sempre la chat così vi di re
silvio
ok o no ossigeno ma sentono l'altro di
ossigeno sta per vincere hanno vinto lì
pure giochiamo che andiamo cappello da
via vediamo cosa sta cosa capite remo
questa volta noi sappiamo già chi sono
gli impostori bianco giallo e nero
numero e non sapete che noi sappiamo chi
sono allora innanzitutto teniamoci
lontani dal bianco già subito proviamo a
pedinare uno degli impostori senza farci
vedere quel ricerchiamo col bianco o
giallo tentato tutto non ci si presenti
segreto oggi via via via via perché no
no non c'è il bianco il mio pastore
attento guerra bianco la sopra il nero
cosa provo aiuto mi chiamo stanno
facendo hanno trovato no non segue
riusciti a vederli proviamo a dire stato
bianco vediamo dove l'hanno trovato sei
super sospetto
[Risate]
non lontano che non andava sappiamo già
li facciamo ogni volta che facciamo da
date bianca votiamo giallo bianco su
fondo giallo che davvero un insaccare
accordo allora siamo rimasti solo noi
godiamo bianchi tutti già a maggio lo è
un impostore bene uno per ora vista la
chiesa non va come attenzione attenzione
attenzione
seguiamo seguiamo nero e giallo hanno
giallo l'abbiamo proponiamo seguiamo
un'eresia
seguiamo nero e bianco che guardava
facendo fini fare le tasche non ci credo
video un poco d'altro bar bianco lo
sappiamo che vedo l'ora di pietro e sarà
andato bianco
ecco
si è nascosto si mimetizzano sui andata
bene perché mi hanno insegnato
vediamo che cosa fa bianco peccato
diagnosi abbiamo visto che ho scritto o
no questa volta beccata anche ammesso
ancora un impostore da trovare che in
realtà noi già sappiamo che ciao bianco
bianco ma quando vedrà questo video che
apriranno in realtà sto per favore
evitiamo molta attenzione ero pediniamo
la paura ho paura che lui adesso si
vendicherà connor e guarda è sparito
ecco lo sappiamo
comunque mi ha fatto troppo ridere non
può stare che facevano finta di fare
l'età ecco la paura si è nascosto ma
questo è questa sta votando un reattore
è sparito
come ha fatto a nascondersi forse
contento forse si è accorto che lo
stavamo seguendo temi a scotto è
possibile ok vediamo lo diciamo di
votare nero aspetta vediamo cosa dicono
maroni dice sei tu umanità
ma il sospetto sia il nero è nero che
celebra non solo per i trucchetti non ho
sofferto ma perché se voi state da
subito e li senti e anche se per ora
vinciamo vetro che è pazzo non era deve
votare ovviamente non muterà stelletta
chi voterà teramo tutti noi ha saltato
invece abbiamo vinto abbiamo dato i tre
punti quindi non è proprio una vincita
vorrei sapere abbiamo trucchetti questa
volta invece di vedere togliamo il
vedere che impostore e mettiamo che
siamo noi e gli impostori in ogni
partita secondo voi si insospettì ranno
se ne accorgeranno di audio che si
chiama rita astori a ciò nota ha tra
l'altro mi avete scritto in un sacco di
commenti che poi giocate su questa
domanda se c'è qualcuno che sta usando
il mio nome e si sta spacciando per
non sono io ecco che vediamo imposte se
ci sono altre due posizioni anche se un
altro l'ha tradita storie un'ipo
fornendo di vedere quando mi
incolperanno è tiranno e anita quale
voteranno comunque comunque non vi
fidate delle persone che vi dicono
online che sonorità stories o che sono
vitale abitanti a uccidendo per lui a
caso tra l'altro bianco sarà molto
arrabbiato contatto che l'abbia a male
rosa non riportava ho visto che sento
che confusione
non sono stata io schifo facciamo tutti
schifo non siamo molto sospetti proprio
siamo ancora più su spettro diciamo di
scappare dobbiamo in per fare qualcuno
non mi fido io ti votiamo bianco ma
perchè non aveva trovato un suo record
poi ha votato non c'era più
l'altra in the stories mista di più del
bianco
ciao ciao scusa si erano di mendoza che
stava in colpa era l'unico che diciamo
la verità tra l'altro queste partite per
bianco sono incredibili quella scorza
che abbiamo subito ma che comunque mi
stavo dicendo no vi fidate se qualcuno
dice che siamo noi online l'unico modo
per capire lo sappiamo realmente noi ed
al mio account instagram che si chiama
anita stories solo lì pubblico i codici
quindi per essere sicuri che siamo noi
vedete se ho pubblicato io il codice
abbiamo vinto grandissimi gli altri sono
tutti gli assuntori e braille
questa volta non abbiamo proprio usato
di trucchetti diciamo che il progetto
era essere imposto ma chi è questo che
dà ampi retto acli cattivo questo la
zucca di cannes dove la più piccola ok
vediamo che dicono prima di iniziare il
capitano era dice anita un po di
confusione
entrambe vediamo se siamo ancora
impostori sì con il trucchetto dovremmo
essere ancora impostori siamo imposti
per ora questa divertente di questo
trucchetto è che tu sei sempre impostore
quindi angelo appunto in altre persone
però non può essere sempre impostare la
sesta persona quindi sicuramente non è
impostore questa volta invece sono bravi
bravi siete stati bravi impostori
riportiamo perché abbiamo già vinto
hanno già ucciso tu che forse due sono
usciti e quindi pensavo stiamo
nuovamente 10 vediamo come funziona
anche questa volta il trucchetto
anche questa volta
in due strada dovrebbero essere tre ma
non lo so quindi vediamo se riescono a
cavarsela questa volta che se c'è
qualcun altro in giro dove si nascondeva
il tempo per farlo ok hanno trovato un
corpo che lo stesso hanno visto stato
giallo che il nostro amico imposte non
ricordo incolpiamo arancione così ne
abbiamo uno in meno bene nessuno allora
dobbiamo far passare qualche secondo
sono ancora tantissimi non so se ce la
faremo questa volta in due impostori che
è stato nero è nero
[Musica]
ho visto i coraggiosi visto è davvero di
un pastore che votiamo nero e speriamo
che tutti siamo cattivi si in questa
partita e no ma per questi sospetteranno
che siamo stati noi se abbiamo detto che
abbiamo visto nero ma vitale ci sono
anch'io
tale rete portiamo giornata stiamo e
vediamo chi no già allora l'altro in
poche ore
se ci fosse un affare quanti ne sono
rimasti vediamo la paura vero no perché
0 l'abbiamo adesso come uno dei sospetti
quindi meglio eliminare qualcun altro
ce la faremo mai da soli siamo in troppi
non troppo più made in più ci stanno
anche seguendo
ecco la trama ektrica del sospetto nero
[Risate]
poverino forse hanno votato davvero
troviamo hanno scoperto ok ciao
dobbiamo barbie celebrare ma due non si
sono 21 praticamente sì basta che ne
prendiamo uno e abbiamo anche da
perfetto per ora tutti sospettati
sicuramente lo sanno che siamo noi
allora facciamo finta di niente finché
non passa il tempo
no no no perché sanno che siamo noi
si aspetta vediamo che la dicono che se
voi stati cattivissimi bravo faceva
capire che noi non andiamo si dicono man
come porto venere possibile che sempre
ci sarà l'ultimo partito è stato troppo
divertente ora salutiamo tutti li
abbiamo salutati anch'io ma io sono
troppo sterili bene queste erano le
nostre partite per i trucchetti e stato
trova divertente se volete che
rigiochiamo con i trucchetti o se
giochiamo normalmente la state un bel mi
piace qua sotto e ora vi lasciamo
quattro vice aprire linee su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
piccate su quella che preferite
ciao
[Musica]